so let's dive in here are our kittens
again by the way that's Liars the boy
kitten on the right we don't have a name
for the girl yet anyway here's what a
picture element looks like you'll notice
that this picture element contains two
source elements you might have seen
those used for video or audio elements
source elements do what you'd expect
they provide optional file sources if
the browser can use the first source at
well otherwise it keeps looking down the
list the picture element is a great way
to provide alternative sources for image
files so the browser can choose
depending on device capabilities we've
used the source element here to specify
web p for browsers that support the web
p format with a JPEG fall back this is a
great way to make use of the high
performance web p format on platforms
that support it while providing an
alternative for platforms that don't you
can find out more about web p from the
article link to below the video by the
way that web p file is massive looks
like i should have saved it with lossy
compression talking about fullbacks
again what about browsers that don't
support the picture element well that's
easy we just include a plain old image
element in fact the image element is non
optional because that's the element that
actually displays the image the picture
element scaffolding certificate in plea
tells the image what source to choose in
fact we can rewrite the example like
this because the browser defaults to the
image element if it can't use any of the
sources earlier on you learnt about art
direction one of the core problems you
have when serving images to a variety of
screen sizes and display sizes is that
although some images scale quite nicely
from large to small other images don't
work so well they may have too much
detail to work well on a small screen or
be too wide to work on a viewport with a
portrait orientation